e
e e
okay it's 10: a.m. uh represent K you
want to Le us on the
pledge okay okay welcome to what will be
the official last meeting of the house
special committee on childcare because
we have no more bills and they're not
sending any more over uh so this is it
um going to open up the executive
session for uh Senate Bill 4 uh 404 and
act directing the Department of Health
and Human Services to submit a report
regarding the establishment of childcare
Workforce childcare assistant pilot
program I'll recognize representative
walner to make a
motion Amendment
57 okay is that seconded by
representative u d Deon representative
second Representative walner makes a
motion of ought to pass uh on Senate
Bill 404 and representative deimon
seconds Representative wner makes a
motion of a to pass as amended with
amendment number can you read it for me
again the amendment number
is18 U amendment number 1571 can just
hand it to me I don't have
front I can read sound that sound dumb
um Amendment 2024 d175 uh 1571 H
represented Deon seconds we are now in
discussion of the amendment is there any
discussion on the amendment yep we're
going to hand the amendment
out it's a secret it's a secret it's a
you have to you have to pass it to see
what's in it that's the
expression um okay
all oh all right represent information
here
all right now representative hner would
you like to speak to your motion hand it
all over here we go represent cre we'll
give you your your clerk duties
back here we go
yay you want to turn your microphone on
repr wner please thank you thank you so
we've
heard for the last couple of years that
um one of the biggest problems facing
child care is the issue around the child
care Workforce and the childcare
Workforce is looking for as many tools
as they can for recruiting
workers what this particular Bill does
is it um
provides that the child care workers
people who work in child care and have
young children that they can um get be
on the child care State scholarship
program so they'll get some
assistance with their cost of child care
um and people feel that that will be a
good recruitment tool so that's what
this bill does the senate sort of
stripped it down and what you have in
front of you is what passed the Senate
Health and Human Service um committee
when it got over to finance it got
stripped down
so the amendment the amendment passed
the Health and Human Service Committee
in the Senate the policy committee they
adopted it as a policy but when it got
to the finance committee it got stripped
down so um what we talked about last
week was bringing back the Health and
Human Service senate committee Amendment
um we know that it would this will go on
to house finance when it if if it passes
the floor so we know that it will go on
to finance and get evaluated for the
financial impact at the finance
committee there's only two changes from
the Health and Human Service committee
amendment that came from the Senate
and one of them is we took out the word
pilot our um esteemed chair does not
like the word pilot he doesn't believe a
pilot is really ever a pilot so um we
took that word out and um what was the
other we did one other what was the
other the edition of the waiver oh yes
we did put in that the Department of
Health and Human Services would uh
request of the federal government that
be we be able to use um federal funds
ask for permission to use federal funds
for this particular project so um and I
don't know if they have already done
that or um we they would be doing it if
for sure if um the bill
passes and I'm open to questions
and any other comments on the bill um
thank you representative wner for
removing the term pilot because no temp
temporary Pro there's nothing more
permanent than a temporary government
program um I am uh I am excited about
the inclusion of the request for the
waiver because that removes any
Financial concerns um my guess is the
feds will likely Grant it um that being
said this is something that came up in
our
um uh basically our fact finding the
vast majority we're talking about
childcare workers who do not qualify
already for the existing state
scholarship the overwhelming vast
majority of chalk workers are already
qualified uh so we're talking about
probably something about I my guess
would be less than 20% of chare workers
don't qualify um and I would actually be
stunned if it was 20% so um I think this
is a good Workforce recruitment tool um
and I think it's uh with the going to
the feds first it kind of mitigates the
um concerns about shifting this burden
onto the New Hampshire taxpayers
although it does have that option if the
FED say no just we're all transparent
but my guess is they're not going to say
no know so I'll be supporting uh the
amendment are there any other uh
questions comments concerns on the
amendment yes representative Thomas
thank you Mr chair um I just want to
make the comment that when I read the
original bill that came over uh 404 um
that my first comment was no guard rails
uh so this amendment answers that and
and yes and so I'm very pleased to see
this amendment thank you yes did you put
the income requirement back in or no I
can't I didn't I didn't look to see it
cuz they already all nobody's making a
million dollar doing this so um anyways
uh with that any other questions
comments concerns on the
amendment hearing none the clerk will
call the role on amendment 20241
15718 to Senate Bill
404 yes
yes
yes representative MC
Williams oh you're paid
yes um represent
long representative
Lane yes and H representative yes I'm
David today uh yes
yes wonderful all right and Mr chair
chair will vote Yes on the amendment um
that Amendment uh carry Amendment 202
24-15 71h Carri is work 10 right yes yes
uh 10 to zero um we are now uh I'm now
recognized represent V Simon to make a
new motion thank you than you Mr chair I
move ought to pass as amended um
representative deimon moves ought to
pass as Amendment on Senate Bill 404
Amendment 202 24-15 71h representative
wner seconds that motion I assume we're
now on discussion of the motion of op
pass as amended is there any discussion
on the motion yes representative Thomas
thank you um just verifying that the
financial note Still Remains the Same
for this amendment yes the financial
note is the same thank
you any other uh further discussion on
the uh bill
as amended hearing none Clark will call
the role on the motion of V to pass as
amended all right um representative beon
yes representative kill yes
representative ball yes representative
Nelson yes representative wner yes
representative crean votes yes
representative long yes representative
Lane yes and representative Thomas yes
andony I would also like to vote oh my
gosh represent chairman Barry chair
votes yes with that uh Senate Bill 404
passes as ought to pass as amended on a
vote of 10 to zero representative dmon
will be responsible for the report which
she'll be off here in the next 30
minutes uh that's the our only business
for today we are adjourned thank you so
much and I'm off to election law